Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today, I’m
going to explain an American science
fiction action film called “Æon Flux.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
A deadly virus wiped out ninety-nine percent of
humanity in 2011. A person named Trevor Goodchild
finds a cure for the virus, and saves one percent
of the human population. The remaining one percent
consists of five million surviving people who now
live in a city called Bregna. The premise of the
movie is set in 2415. Four hundred and four years
after the pandemic, the city of Bregna has changed
completely. At first glance, it looks like
a perfect utopian city with happy people
and a better quality of life. Massive concrete
walls surround the circular city to stop people
from going outside the premises and potentially
catching the virus. Bregna is technologically
advanced and has a massive spaceship-like
object levitating over the city. For the past
four hundred years, the Goodchild dynasty has
been ruling the city. However, the government
hides a secret from its people. Many people vanish
mysteriously and frequently, and no one knows why.
Even weirder, is that the whole population gets
strange nightmares, and the government requests
it to be treated. Everyone suspects that it is the
government that is involved in the disappearances,
but no one is brave enough to stand against the
Goodchilds, except for a group of people called
the Monicans. Monicans is an underground rebel
organization that aims to get the answers to the
frequent disappearance and fight against
the absolute rule of the Goodchilds.
The protagonist of the movie, Æon
Flux, is a highly skilled assassin
and a warrior who works secretly with the
Monicans. At the beginning of the movie,
we see her walking through the streets of the
beautiful city. She meets a man at a junction,
and the two kiss. We see the man transfer a pill
from his mouth to hers as they kiss. When the two
separate and go their own way, Æon takes the
pill. It is an advanced telepathic technology
used by the Monicans to communicate with each
other. By taking the pill, Æon is able to talk
to the leader of the Monicans named Handler. She
provides her with a new mission, to sabotage the
Goodchild’s central surveillance facility. Later,
we see Æon walk through a busy street in the city.
An old man shows people a picture of his
daughter, asking if someone has seen her.
Æon meets her younger sister Una, and the
two plan to meet for dinner that night.
After her meeting with Una, she goes to the
Goodchild’s headquarter, and very swiftly kills
the three guards outside. She goes further in and
defeats the other guards too. They do not match
Æon’s fighting and spying skills. She jumps inside
through the roof, and sees the life of every
person in the city being watched through some kind
of technology. Æon then plants a bug in the place
and completes her mission successfully.
That night, Æon is going to Una’s apartment,
but on her way, she sees two men carrying her
body away. She is shocked and freezes in her
tracks. Some guards bring Una’s boyfriends
behind her. He looks at Æon and tells her
that Una wasn’t a Monican, suggesting that she was
killed for being misunderstood as a Monican.
Æon cannot stop thinking about her sister
at night, she pledges to take revenge on the
people who got her killed. A microphone embedded
permanently on her ear tells her that Handler
wants to see her. She uses telepathic technology
to meet the leader. She hands her a new mission,
the most important mission they have had yet. It
is to kill the man who made the cure and chairman
of the Goodchild’s rule, Trevor Goodchild. Æon
accepts the mission delightedly, because she
is getting a chance to kill the murderer of her
sister. Handler blows her pollen from a flower,
and embeds Æon with the plan of the mission.
Sithandra, Æon’s friend and a fellow member of the
Monican will help her cross the border, which is
the first step of the mission. The following day,
Æon and Sithandra start the plan. They run
through the restricted premises of the Goodchild’s
residence, and are shot by several weapons planted
on the trees. Sithandra helps Æon to get through
the traps and leaves her to complete the rest of
the mission alone, and waits outside for her.
Inside the massive residence, we see Trevor
Goodchild talk to his brother and a co-member
of their government, Oren Goodchild. The two
talk about a system their world is working on.
Trevor is actively trying to better the said
system, because it harms the people currently,
but Oren is in the favor of continuing the current
system even though it is hurting the people.
Sometime later, Æon finds Trevor in an auditorium
practicing a speech. She comes in front of him
and points her gun at him. However, before she can
pull the trigger, Trevor calls her Katherine. Æon
gets a flashback of two people kissing and cannot
seem to shoot him. Someone from behind her knocks
her unconscious. When she opens her eyes, she is
in a cell. One of the walls becomes transparent,
revealing Trevor standing on the other side. Æon
asks him about calling her Katherine earlier,
but Trevor doesn’t tell her why he did. He claims
it is good to see her again, and leaves.
A part on the wall reverses, offering her food
and water. But Æon suspects that the water is
spiked by looking through her microscope embedded
in her eyes. She takes a sample of it with her.
She then calls on some marbles that she had
spread throughout the facility. The marbles
explode creating an opening, through which Æon
runs away. Then we see Oren and other members of
the government, who aren’t fond of Trevor’s idea,
talk about Æon’s escape. Oren dismisses them all
but later meets Trevor’s secretary, Inari. As
they talk, we get to know that Oren was the one
who manipulated the Monicans into wanting to kill
Trevor. He wants his brother dead and wants to do
it discreetly, so his death won’t track back
to him. Æon then goes to see Una’s boyfriend,
who tells her that the liquid she was given has a
message that will be told to her when she drinks
it. Æon then drinks the liquid and Trevor talks to
her in her head. He asks her why she didn’t kill
him earlier when she had a chance, and then he
calls her to a place. Æon rushes to go meet him.
She asks him for an answer to all this, but
he instead questions her why she is here,
wanting her to remember the truth herself. In the
heat of the moment, the two kiss. After a while,
Æon wakes up naked beside Trevor and is confused.
She doesn’t know what took over her earlier.
She strangles him and knocks him out. Æon
then finds a secret door leading to a library.
An armor suddenly latches to her and brings
her to Trevor’s lab. She sees that he has been
performing some kind of experiment. But just
then, she is confronted by Trevor’s personal
security and assistant, Freya. Freya knows
her as the assassin sent to kill her boss,
so she attacks her. The women get into an
intense fight, both equally skilled. In the end,
Æon manages to escape through a secret opening.
When Trevor comes back to consciousness,
Freya tells him that she escaped and he asks
her to bring Æon back alive. Oren and the other
officials see that Trevor and Freya have slept
together. They believe that Trevor has betrayed
their trust by welcoming a member of the Monican,
so they want him to dethrone him altogether.
She goes back to meet Sithandra and tells her she
has aborted the mission. They get into an argument
after which, Æon ties Sithendra and runs
away. She sees the floating structure in the
sky through which the Goodchilds keep an eye on
the citizens. She climbs up to reach it. Inside,
she sees a strange man controlling a strange
panel. The man sees Æon and welcomes her back. He
points towards a direction and disappears, leaving
a confused Æon to do whatever she likes.
She goes to the panel and realises the device
has information about everyone in the city,
so she searches for her sister’s name. As
it turns out Una has been reborn as Sasha
Prillo. Æon is shocked, she gets her address
and runs to see her sister. Meanwhile, Sithandra
informs Handler about Æon’s betrayal. Handler
assigns more members of the Monicans to eliminate
Æon. Trevor reaches the flying object and meets
the man who happens to be the ship’s keeper.
After knowing she went to see her sister,
Trevor runs there too. Æon holds her baby
sister with teary eyes when Trevor reaches there.
He finally reveals to her the truth about Bregna.
When the virus first spread four hundred years
ago, Trevor and a group of scientists developed
the cure and saved some of the world. But the cure
had a terrible side effect, it made all the women
infertile. So, humans only had that one generation
to live. However, Trevor saved them when his
cloning experiment was successful. He cloned the
DNA of every person alive and gave them a rebirth.
Every person who has been born for the past four
hundred years is a clone of the ones who were
cured. That is why people have strange dreams, the
dreams are the memories of their past lives. That
is also the reason, the population of the place
has remained five million for all these centuries.
When a person dies in the city, the ship’s keeper
recycles their DNA and assigns it to someone else.
The citizens are unknown to this and think
they have a natural pregnancy. But in reality,
the keeper of the floating ship finds a suitable
couple to impregnate and induce the woman with a
chemical pregnancy. When they visit the doctor
to see if they are pregnant, the cloned embryo
is planted on her. That way, she gives birth to
a clone of someone who had recently died.
For the past seven generations, Trevor and Oren
have cloned themselves and taught their younger
versions all the things they need to know. Then
Trevor also tells Æon that this method is not
permanent and he has been looking for a way to
reinduce natural pregnancy for all these years.
Turns out, Una was subject to Trevor’s experiment
who had successfully been pregnant naturally,
but Oren killed her because he wants the cloning
process to go on forever, so he can live forever.
He wants to be immortal. As Æon looks at her
sister, the place is attacked by Oren’s men.
But with Æon’s fighting skills, she protects
Trevor, and the two manage to run away from the
place, while being pursued by the men. They reach
a train station and escape by boarding a train,
however, Trevor has been shot. Æon quickly takes
him to a nearby quiet area and takes the bullets
out of his body. She peels off her skin and puts
it on his, healing his wounds. Trevor then claims
that they have to go to his lab to collect his
files on the experiment he performed on Una, so he
could induce natural pregnancy again. Æon asks him
about their relationship and Trevor claims that
she was Katherine, his wife four hundred years
ago. Oren has told Trevor that she died because of
the virus, but her DNA clone was protected. Æon is
beyond surprised but they do not have much time to
chat. When the two reach his lab, they see Freya
dead and all his reports have been burned.
Trevor wants to run away from the city, but Æon
insists on doing one last task before leaving.
She wants to destroy the floating ship because
she believes that cloning is playing with nature.
Humans are supposed to die and she
doesn’t want that to change anymore.
But before she can shoot the ship down,
Oren and his men surround the two.
At the same time, Sithandra and her
monicans team climb at a high point
to assassinate Æon. Oren then reveals to Trevor
that more and more women started getting pregnant,
not because of Trevor’s experiment, but because
they were healing from the cure’s side effects.
So, he killed them all, including Una. That is why
the citizens have been disappearing mysteriously.
He now plans to kill both of them and continue
the world of cloning. As they talk, Æon notices
Sithandra far away. She uses telepathy technology
to convince her to help them. Sithendra and her
group begin to shoot at the guards to save Trevor
and Æon. During the shootout, Oren is injured.
Sithandra’s group manages to kill most of Oren’s
guards. However, an injured Oren shoots Sithandra
and drops her off the height, killing her.
In the end, Trevor and Oren come face to face.
Æon shoots Oren dead when he points his gun at
Trevor. Æon then gets on the ship and explodes it,
destroying the DNA clones stored in it. The
ship goes flying and lands harshly on the city’s
perimeter wall. The people see the outside world
for the first time. It seems fertile and full of
vegetation, a land that can be inhabitable.
The movie ends as we see a glance of Æon and
Trevor’s life four hundred years ago.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thank you for watching.